hello everyone this is the talk called
lazy programmers guide to writing
thousands of tests
it's about property based testing if
you're if you're not a lazy programmer
maybe this talk will not be of interest
to you but like most people I'm in fact
a lazy programmer so I don't want to
write lots of code if I don't have to
and it's probably based testing is one
way to avoid doing that so my name is
Scott lotion and there we go Scott
flushing f shot fun and profit calm so
the examples in this talk will be can
f-sharp code but it's the language is
not really important that is the
concepts that importance and these
concepts apply to pretty much any
programming language so here we are the
NDC community unfortunately is a social
distancing so I'm working from home like
you are hopefully we can all stay safe
and still have some fun right so um in
order to set this up I'm going to tell
you a story it's a semi made-up story
part of it's true and part of it isn't I
kind of exaggerated but I mean I was
working with the remote developer a long
time ago in a galaxy far far away and
for the benefit the story I'm just going
to say that we needed a function that
would add two numbers together okay it
was more complicated in reality but
they'll go how do you add two numbers
together and so the remote developer
says sure I've just finished adding the
add function I'm happy and I say have
you written unit tests and they say you
want unit tests as well yeah okay they
kind of sent us a price so they wrote a
test you know given inputs of one and
three I would expect the output is four
that was their unit test and then they
say I think can we call it done and I
would say or actually you know that's
only one test how do you know it doesn't
fail for other inputs it's just like one
and three so they say okay let me write
another unit test
and they said okay I just wrote another
awesome unit test they thought they were
you know certain kind of develop who
said that kind of thing
two and two is four and that's an
awesome unit test and I wasn't so
impressed I said you know you're testing
for special cases how do you know it
doesn't fail for other tests do you
haven't thought of I know and he was
like you want more tests I've only
written to well how much do you want and
that is a good question
how do you know they have written enough
tests and this is quite a deep question
how do you know that you have enough
tests is to test enough five tests a
hundred tests how the top point of
testing is to gain confidence in the
implementation and you can have 100%
test coverage and still have you know
bad implementation and you can have you
know a small test coverage but still
have very high confidence in the
implementation and so that's one of the
things that we're going to try and talk
about so in this case I didn't trust
this person to write unit tests so I
thought I'd write them myself so I had a
look at the existing test this is f
sharp code here when I add one and three
I expect four I now do the add function
and I assert that the the answer is four
and that passed okay and then let me
write another tester for two and two and
I call the add function and I expect the
answer to be four okay so that's good
that one passed the test
so let me write a test okay so when I
add minus one and three let me do
something tricky I have minus 103 and
I'll expect the answer to be two and
this test fails so I thought okay well
that's kind of funny let me go and look
at the implementation let's just check
and see how everything is so here's the
implementation
to add your numbers together return for
okay and in F sharp you don't need a
return keyword so that was the entire
implementation and I was like what what
is this this is terrible so I wrote back
and I said I'm gonna write the tests and
you're gonna make them class okay
I don't trust him and he said sure no
worries
so let me write some more tests I'm
gonna two and three I expect five and he
wrote his implementation past that that
okay and then if I do let's say one and
forty one I'd expect forty two and that
test also passed so okay maybe maybe
he's a implementation is getting better
so let me just check the implementation
though just to be sure so this is the
implementation and if the if the input
is 2 and 3 the answer is five and if the
input is 1 and 41 the answer is 42 and
in all other cases the input the answers
for and you know like this is not a very
good implementation this is not a very
good implementation and I'm saying so I
said you what are you even doing you
haven't even implemented anything yet
you've just made the test pass and he
said chill out I'm totally following TDD
best practices which is you write only
enough code to make the failing unit
test pass and that's exactly what he was
doing and you know I think this sir I'm
not sure that's quite what they meant
when they said that but you know he's
following it literally okay so I thought
let me just try and make it more
complicated I'm gonna have a whole set
of test data a whole array of test data
and for each answer in the array I'm
going to see if the the actual answer
matches the expected answer and that
passed and I
look at implementation again and of
course you can guess what he did
basically every possible thing that was
in the input was hard-coded so this we
have a problem
houston we have a problem here it dawned
on me that I was dealing with a certain
kind of person
the legendary burned-out lazy malicious
programmer called the enterprise
developer from hell and you might have
in your life of developer you've fully
met people like this they are lazy and
they're also malicious and they also are
not they sometimes they just try and
make life worse for everybody else so
and I've used the evil Garfield's as the
symbol for this person so I gotta
rethink my approach the enterprise
developer from hell will always make
specific examples pass no matter what I
do so what can I do I have to not use
specific examples but how can I write a
test without having any examples of what
I want okay
so let's use random numbers so this way
he can't guess what they are so I take a
random integer and another random
integer and I put down the expected
answer and I put the actual answer that
I got from calling this function and I
check that the answers are equal and
this is fantastic
let me just do it a hundred times just
in case he gets lucky with the two
random numbers so I'm gonna do a hundred
times it's just so it's not a
coincidence okay so there's the final
test at a hundred times take two random
integers add them together and make sure
that when we call our new add function
that the the same answer so this is
break this is great that the enterprise
developer for hell cannot possibly beat
this implementation this test however
however we have a bit of a problem
because I have basically re-implemented
I'm using the built in addition function
and if if it was a brand new kind of
functionality I'd have to re-implement
the functionality in the tests to check
whether I got
my answer and this is a really common
problem interesting is you'd basically
have to re-implement what you want in
order to test it and that's you know
that's an anti-pattern you do not want
to be reimplemented things to check that
they work so this is a problem so how
can we fix this how can we fix the
problem of implementing ads without
using the add function all right so if
you can't test it by comparing it with
something what you know how can we test
it so how would you write this is a
question for everyone listening how
would you write a test for an ad
function without Eitri implementing a
door without using any of the built-in
libraries and without using any specific
examples like two plus two equals four
so that's the challenge and this leads
us to property based testing so in order
to implement it we need to know what the
requirements are and what are the
requirements for the add function it's
hard to know to get started with these
things but one way is to think about if
you don't know what the arts are my
answer is you could often compare it
with the wrong answer so we don't know
what ads should do but we know that our
Edition is different from subtraction
how does addition differ from
subtraction well one simple thing is
that the parameter order makes
difference so in addition it doesn't
matter which order the parameters are
but its attraction it does you know five
minus two is not the same as two minus
five so we could write a test for that
okay so that's a little difference we
can write a test for so here's our test
that checks that little thing so we say
that whatever the thing is it doesn't
depend on parameter order so we take a
we do what we did before we take a
hundred different random numbers and we
add them together and we also add them
together with the parameters reversed
okay and then we check that we have the
same answer and if we do have the same
answer you know it's a it's a it's a
quite good test it's not a hundred
percent perfect but it certainly
lemonade's through the [ __ ] so of
subtraction
and it's a whole bunch of incorrect
implementations have been eliminated
this way now of course the enterprise
developer from hell is clever and
they're evil and they will respond with
this implementation to add two numbers
together you multiply them now this
passes the the test is particularly easy
as being a very very evil today
unfortunately this test passes with this
bad implementation but we get the hang
of it here we can keep doing the same
thing so what's the difference between
addition and multiplication well that's
a bit trickier but you know a simple one
is if you add one just and you do it
twice that's the same as adding two but
if you multiply by one twice that's not
the same as multiplying by two so let's
turn that into a test as well we're
going to call it to adding ones two of
adding ones is the same as one or two so
here you go so again we'll take our
random number we'll add one and we'll
add one again and the second one is
we'll add two and they should be the
same answer now this will eliminate the
multiplication implementation so that
passes but the enterprise developer then
says ok I'm going to implement this with
minus y with subtraction and and this
part it says because subtracting 1 twice
is the same as subtracting 2 so when I
try and do this test this test will now
pass with subtraction as the
implementation but we have the previous
test as well so when I add two numbers
that number that doesn't depend on
parameter order so that the previous
test now fails so if the combination of
these two tests is what narrows it down
each individual test eliminates a set of
things and when you combine the two
tests they they really start narrowing
it down a lot so can the interface
developer from he'll come up with a
a test that implementation that will
fail let's see but yes he can
this is his implementation to add two
numbers together you return zero and
actually this passes all the tests
because you know doing it twice that
passes and it doesn't depend on the
parameter that passes so okay how can we
write another kind of test that
eliminates this kind of implementation
and the problem is that we're not we
haven't really understood addition
because there is somehow the addition
function is the output has to be
connected to the input somehow right it
does depend on the input but we don't
want to have we don't always know how it
depends on the input because without
actually we implementing it but is there
a trivial input that we do know the
answer to like without having to be
implementing a thing is there enough is
there an input of add that we always
know what the answer will be and the
answer is yes if you add zero to
something that's the same as doing
nothing
so let's write a test for that okay so
we're going to take do it for a hundred
times to do a random integer we're going
to add zero to it and then we're also
going to have the original number and
they should be the same I you should be
untouched so if we add this extra test
to it this actually will pretty much
defeat the enterprise developer from
hell we have this tests we have this
test and we have this test and if you
combine these three tests together any
particular implementation will be much
harder to use much harder to have a
sneaky thing in fact this is not hundred
percent perfect I mean this is pretty
true there is actually one one way of
making this fail but we can extend this
idea to make it so it's literally
impossible to fail
so that's the idea of property based
testing we're not tasting individual
examples we're testing properties of the
function the fact that the this
independent of parameter order that's a
property of the function no matter what
the inputs are is always true it's an
invariant of them of the function adding
zero is the same as doing nothing that's
always true no matter what number you
have is input so without using specific
examples we've narrowed down the
implementation of ads so let's refactor
this out let's extract the shared code
we've got a lot of common code here so
what we're going to do is write a method
or a function called property check and
it has a parameter which is the property
function this is what we're going to be
passing in then in this particular case
the property function takes a pair of
integers as input and returns a boolean
is out but it always returns true or
false and so our generic property
function looks like this we take a
random integer we take another round of
integer and we call this property
function with these two integers and the
result is either true or false okay and
we always want the result to be true
this property should always be true and
if it is always true then we have a good
then the property we have a good idea
that the property passes okay so this
property function technically as a
function we just generally call it a
property it's like something that's
always true the set of inputs and so
this is basically probably pieces are
basically we've written our property
based testing framework right here it's
not a favor because it's a single
function but that's how simple it is
right so this is what the test looked
like we have a property function which
is like the cumulative property where
the parameter order doesn't matter and
the property function just like takes
the two inputs calls the function with
with the infants reversed and the answer
should be the same and then our tests
are actual tests look like this we have
a test for the particular thing and we
just check that that particular property
function is always true for random
inputs
so this is the second property now we
only need one of the two inputs but
here's the example he's written as a
property we add it once where it twice
and the answer should be the same so it
always always returns a billion these
properties are always boolean returning
functions and again if we want to use it
in a tests we take this boolean
returning function and we pass it into
our property checking thing which has
been it checks that property for a
hundred random inputs okay now if you're
a mathematician you'd recognize adding
one twice it's basically a very crude
version of associativity so the real
prop the real addition property is
associative it'll and the third one
adding zero we call this the identity
property if you add zero it's the same
as doing nothing and we're going to test
using that and there we go so let's
review what we've got the parameter
order doesn't matter doing add one twice
is the same as doing it that's adding
two and adding zero doing nothing these
properties apply to all the inputs no
matter what they are no matter how
random they are these things are always
true so we have a very high confidence
going back to my original statement we
haven't tested all four billion inputs
but by choice by choosing random inputs
and they always work out we have a high
confidence that the implementation is
correct so these we basically written
three tests and rather than three
example tests we actually have three
property tests now these things have
words in in in mathematics we call this
community to commutativity associativity
and identity and this is not just a test
this is actually now a specification and
anything that implements these three
properties is addition and that actually
defines addition so by defining it you
literally can't
if you pass these three tests of these
three properties that meets the
specification of what addition is so you
literally cannot create an incorrect
implementation
so that's the idea behind property based
testing you can see it's pretty
straightforward it's something you could
write yourself in a few minutes if you
wanted to but yeah I just want to
re-emphasize that by using this kind of
property specification approach we've
actually understood the requirements in
a much deeper way if we just said that
two plus two is four that's just an
example of what addition is because two
times two is also four it doesn't really
narrow it down it doesn't really tell
you what it's a true meaning of the
thing is if we use specifications like
this we it really helps to understand
drive a deeper understanding of what we
really really want the system to do
right so why bother with this example
you know this kind of malicious
programmer is realistic very unrealistic
very over-the-top
nobody would ever do this surely so
here's a way of thinking about it we
have evil people we have stupid people
and we have lazy people and it doesn't
actually matter which kind of person
you're dealing with because whether
they're evil stupid or lazy they will
still mess up your codes stupid people
can cause bad bugs just as much as evil
people so you know it doesn't really
make any difference and there's actually
one person I've always had to deal with
one particular stupid person in my
career that I've dealt with a lot which
is kind of frustrating is the stupid
person it's me and when I'm writing code
for the first time in a new project I
often don't understand the requirements
and I often write code that I'm not
happy with and it often has bugs because
they didn't understand something
properly and so I am really am the wheel
enterprise developer help myself
especially myself from six months ago
who was too lazy or too stupid to do
something and I'm sure that a lot of you
have the same experience you look at old
code and you think yeah I could have
done this complete in a different way
because now that I'm older and I
understand the system better I could
probably write it in a much better way
so that just comes from you know there's
nothing wrong that happens to all of us
this just comes with learning about the
system better right so it's not because
I'm evil but just because I'm unaware
and I'm blind sometimes so doing the
thinking and this is the lazy thing
we're too lazy to think if right if I
had spent more time thinking about the
properties that would probably help me
get better tests and also it ask helps
me understand the requirements better if
I ask well what is a property that
always has to be true if I can't come up
with a good answer it means that I
probably don't understand the system yet
all right so that's the home home made
way of doing probably based testing but
let's look at a a library you don't
really want to write your own test this
way and the library is called quick
check and it's a toolkit for doing
property based testing it was originally
developed for Haskell but the ideas are
now available pretty much every
programming language has a property
based testing framework or sometimes
it's called quick check framework very
very good I highly recommend that you
look into these so this is how it works
you have this library has an API and
inside there's two things called a
generator and a shrinker which I will
talk about so you have your property
which remember is a function and it's a
function that returns boolean you pass
it in to this API and the first thing is
that the generator part generates random
inputs to you know to generate random
inputs for your function but then the
second part the shrinker is crates
minimal failing inputs the problem with
having completely random inputs is they
might be some incredibly random large
number and it doesn't really tell you
what's gone wrong you know says yeah
well this thing failed if you pass in
475 billion or something but yeah that's
not very helpful in understanding what's
going on so having a minimal failing
input is really really useful
so let's start off with showing you some
codes so here is our correct
implementation of ads using the built-in
library so here's our property that
should always be true no matter what the
inputs are and then in F sharp which is
what I'm using you just say check this
property using the built in quick check
library so that's its that's how simple
doing it is it sounds like it's
something kind of complicated but it's
actually really simple it's just a few
lines of code and when we do this test
if everything runs well we'll say a
message like this we passed a hundred
tests so we put it is a generator 200
random inputs for this property and
every single one of them return true
right so let's look at how the generator
works because it's kind of interesting
first of all those generators for all
the primitive types is an int generator
there's a string generator which is
really useful because it generates
random unicode strings with
non-printable characters and all sorts
of weird things in it which you might
not normally think about if you're
testing your strings is a billion
generators it just generates random
billions true and false whatever so
there's the kind of basic primitive
generators and then what you can do is
you can generate compound types so if
you want to generate pairs of integers
you just say I want you to generate
pairs of integers and it will it will do
that you know each part of the pair is
going to be a different integer in
functional program we have the optional
type and so you can generate optional
types the same way it'll sometimes it'll
be something and sometimes would be
nothing and if you have your own custom
type so I'm here I'm defining a custom
type in F sharp and it's three different
choices it's just kind of like an enum
you can think of it there's a red case
there's a green case and a blue case and
green case there's an integer associated
with it and in the blue case there's a
boolean associated with it so this
custom type the quick check Lloyd we
will normally be able to handle it
nicely
it'll just generate random
implement instances of this thing too so
a random green a random red around and
blue another round of green and so on so
in functional languages we have
something called algebraic data types or
I like to call them composable data
types because in a composable type
system bigger types are built from
smaller types just like using Lego and
because they're built from smaller types
if you can generate random data for the
smaller types you can also generate
random data for the bigger types because
they're just composed from the smaller
types so it really really fits well with
property based testing unlike the
object-oriented style of defining
classes which doesn't really fit so well
right so here is our property of any
users property again and we have these
two parameters X and y and when you pass
it in to the checker it says it's
figures out these are integers so it
will generate it automatically figure
out I need to generate pairs of integers
so it generates pairs of integers and
then it passes them into the property
and it does it for a hundred times and
then it sees if it's true for every time
so this is how the the checker works at
the crude level basically so again it's
something you could write quite easily
right now here's the here's the nice
part which is this shrinker components
for dealing with failure I'm going to
demonstrate this I'm going to use a very
crude example which is we have a
property called the number is smaller
than 81 now this property will obviously
fail for numbers that are bigger than 81
so we we know this property will fail
but let's see if the shrinker can help
us figure out exactly what the boundary
saw if we did this property with our
random one that we we implemented by
ourselves it would just generate random
integers and it might fail with you know
like say some very large random number
which really wouldn't be very helpful to
help us narrow down what good problem is
so let's see what we can do here so we
know this is going to fail so
the quick check will generate a whole
bunch of random integers and it's up to
hundred now all the other ones pass and
when it gets to hundreds it fails right
now well than just saying it failed with
the hundreds we're gonna start again and
see if we can narrow it down okay
so what can we do well what we do is we
generate numbers smaller than 100 which
is why it's called shrinking so we
generate numbers up to a hundred and see
see how it works so when you generate
numbers up to a hundred it doesn't
generate all of them it checks kind of
very a serial kind of a diminishing
series that it Domitian insecure close
to the answer so in this case it
generates 0 50 75 88 94 97 and 99 now in
this case when we run those numbers
through the property it fails at 88 okay
well that's good we're just going to
start again so now we're going to start
shrinking from 88 and this will generate
all the numbers up to 88 44 66 77 83 and
83 it fails so let's do it again
so here's our list for 83 and we have 42
63 70 381
so it fails at 81 all right and now we
do it again so we generate all numbers
up to 81 now if we want this these ones
all pass so we know that all the ones up
to 8 up to 81 pass but 81 fails so it
has figured out that 81 is the smallest
failing input which is great so when we
run this thing if we if we if we ran it
interactively it actually says the
answer is its falsifiable meaning that
there are some values where the property
is false
it did 23 tests it did three shrinks and
the smallest failing one is 81 so it
literally tells us where the boundaries
are in our airplane our errors which is
really really really nice and it works
for more compound types obviously I used
integers as a simple example but it will
work for more complicated types as well
to try and find a smallest
thing that will fail the test right so
that's how property testing works and
people when they see this they say this
is great but when it actually when they
try and do something they kind of get
stuck it's like how do I even choose a
property for my system so you know what
properties should I use I can't think of
any when you actually try and do it so
I'm going to show you some properties
that you can use to get some ideas from
so the first one this is probably the
most useful one in general is that you
take different paths but you get to the
same destination so if you start off
with ABC and you do something and you do
something you end up at 1 2 3 and if
you'd go in a different direction you
also end up 1 2 3 so for example
commutativity which is if you do in one
order you get art so if you do it in a
different order you would get the same
answer associativity is another example
map Monad laws front two laws these are
all the same kinds of things I'm not
going to get into that right now but let
me show you a concrete example let's say
that you wanted you've got an
implementation for sorting a list and
you want to check whether your
implementation is correct
now as sue said you don't want to write
a whole bunch of examples to see if
you're if you're sorting implementation
it's correct you want to have it whole
you know when a different random data so
how can we do that well if we if we take
this approach what we're going to do is
we're going to manipulate the list and
then sort it that's going to be one way
and then in the other way we're going to
sort it first and then manipulate the
list and hopefully we end up at the same
answer so what we're going to do is
we're going to manipulate the list by in
negating all the numbers in the list and
then sorting it and now you know minus
three should be the first answer now if
we do the only around if we sort the
list first and then we negate all the
numbers and then we have to reverse the
list as well we should end up with the
same sorted list the same answer
and if this is if this is always true
then we probably have a good
implementation of sorting the list let's
say you want to map something so the map
is a transform applied to an object of a
type and I'm going to use an example
from Kent Beck's unit testing book a
long time ago where he used currency as
an example so I want to check that um if
I manipulate currencies that it's my
code is working and again I don't want
to wait some unit tests
I want to be sure that it's pretty much
working for everything so if I create a
currency and then I transform it somehow
that should be the same as transforming
the data before I create the currency so
let's say the transformation I'm going
to do is just multiply by three so if I
if I create a currency with two in it
and then I map it to multiply it by
three that should be a currency with six
in it hopefully and then if I do they
around if I start off with two and I
multiply by three and then I create that
currency I should end up at the same
point so if I don't end up at the same
point my map function is probably wrong
and so this is a nice for things like
mapping or you know in length this would
be called select it's a great way to
test these kinds of functions because
you don't really care what the inputs
are so another common pattern for
properties is doing something and then
going backwards there and back again
let's say you want to serialize
something and then you deserialize it
you should end up at the same place if
you add something and subtract something
you should end up at the same place if
you write something and then read it you
should have the same data they're not
exact they're not little inverses but
it's basically going in one direction
and coming back in the other direction
setting a property and then getting the
property you know you would expect these
two it to work so very very common ways
of doing testing class examples doing a
list if you reverse a list and universes
again you should end up with the
original answer now obviously there's
you know you could also just do nothing
to list so this is not the only property
that you need but it's a useful very
easy property to test and this is a very
important point it's very rare that one
individual property will do everything
you often need a combination of
properties not just one just like we had
for addition the individual properties
you know they eliminated some of them
but the combination of the three
properties together was what really
narrowed it down so here's a really
helpful property for this kind of thing
which is when you transform something
something about it is still same for
example the size of a collection you
know if you sort a collection the size
is the same if you map over flexion the
size is the same if you reverse a
flexion the size is the same the
contents of a collection they don't
change when you sort it they don't
change when you reverse it you often
have you know things like balance trees
would have there's some property that
even if you add things that are bound to
trees or move things around streets that
they're still balanced that's but the
definition some you know invariant they
have so we had this list sorting example
before and I said that was a pretty good
test but of course we haven't taken into
account the enterprise developer from
hell who will try and come up with an
implementation that passes this tests in
an evil way right so this is the we can
even beat this test if you're evil so
the evil sorts the implementation of
evil sort is literally just returning an
empty lists so if you negate it and then
sort it you get an empty list if you
sort it first you get an empty lists so
no matter what you do you get an empty
lists and so these paths are the same
thing so this is one property but
there's a workaround you know to make it
a bad implementation so how can we
improve this property so that the
enterprise developer from Hell can not
have an evil sort implementation so this
passes the tests okay so bad Garfield's
well
we can say some things never change no
matter what you do when you sort a list
the output is going to be a permutation
of the original list it has to have the
same context and this will kill their
evil sort so anyway so the evil the the
the salting thing will check whether
it's sorted and then this extra property
that the list is has the same contents
will also stop the evil implementation
so these two properties together will
pretty much prove that list is sorted
okay so that beats the enterprise
Darrell from hell and this is the kind
of thing you have to do is you have to
have multiple properties here's another
one when you do something twice you end
up with the same answer so if you if you
make a distinct if you make a distinct
collection and then you make it another
missing collection it's the same as the
first time idempotence this is a good
property sorting if you sort it and you
saw it again is still sorted if you do a
filter and then you filter in it it's
like doing it the first time if you
process an event and then you process
that same event again really nothing
should happen if you're doing any kind
of distributed design this is a really
really important property that some it's
been you know handling events twice
don't it's the same as handling event
once Smalling a solver problem solving
AF solving a small problem is a very
common thing if you can have a property
which works for a small bit and you can
extend it to the big bit that's a nice
way of doing it and it really often
works when it when that when this
solution is also done the same way
though for example quicksort in that of
a list is you sought smaller lists and
then you add them together to make a
bigger list so if you have those kinds
of implementations you can also have
those kinds of properties so any kind of
divide and conquer algorithm will be
amenable to this kind of property any
kind of structural induction like your
recursive data structure you can use
this kind of thing for it so very useful
here's another
one issue one into quite a lot which is
there are things which are quite hard to
prove but they're quite easy to verify
so if I have an algorithm that figures
out how to get through a maze you know
it's hard to know it's hard to prove
that algorithm works however if it does
give me a path it's really easy to check
whether that path goes through the maze
or not so it's often easy to check
things even though it's hard to
implement them and the classic example
of this is prime number factorization
you know it's really easy it's very hard
to factorize numbers but if you do have
them if someone gives you some factors
it's really easy to multiply them and
prove that they add up to the big number
many many examples of this I'm not even
going to go into them but this is just
to show you some gives you some ideas of
different kinds of things you can do so
here's an example let's say you have two
tokenize a string in two with using
commas or any kind of token or any kind
of parsing organization it's kind of
hard to prove that the tokenizer
works especially if it's a complicated
parsing thing these are various it's if
one let's say you just need to split
something at the commas and you get
after you split it you get three
different sub strings now testing the
implementation is quite hard but testing
the outputs it's quite easy you just
take these three strings and you combine
them and you should get the same string
as what the input was and so there's an
example where it's easy to verify that
the output is correct even though it's
quite hard to implement it and then a
more complicated thing if you have a
parser that builds up sort of
complicated parse tree you know it can
be quite complicated to check the parser
but if you take the parse tree and you
regenerate the original source codes you
know that's a good way of checking
whether your part is working on
look at the sorting thing again people
unfortunately with probably based
testing people use very simple examples
and I'm not going to be an exception the
reason is it's hard to explain the stuff
on the slide so people use lists sorting
and list reversing and things real world
property based testing is much more
complicated in that and I will give you
some resources for that at the end of
the talk we can check them out all right
so let's say that we want to have
something is really easy to prove that a
list is sorted well it's kind of hard to
prove that an entire list is sorted
however it's really easy to check that
the pairs the adjacent pairs are you
know the first one is less than the
second one so it for each pair of
numbers in the list it's pretty easy to
check that they're you know they're
related that way so if the individual
pairs are related that way then
hopefully the list as a whole is sorted
but again we need the property that the
the entire contents is a it's the same
as again we could have the evil sort way
just return an empty lists and that
would pass too so that's a quick way of
verifying that something sorted now the
final one is something called the test
Oracle and test article is where you
have a system under tests and you have
some other system the test Oracle the
that does have the right answer and what
you do is you run the system under tests
and then you run the test Oracle and you
compare the answers and if you think
about that's really what example based
testing is to you your brain knows what
the right answer is and you compare it
with what your system says but in in
real world you have to have much more
complicated test articles for example
you have an optimized version of an
algorithm and you have the brute force
version and you know that the
proportional works but it's really slow
so you can compare the brute force
version with the optimized version and
if they give the same answer for every
input then you have confidence that your
optimized one is actually correct
what and another example is parallel
versus single threads so you have a
single thread version that you know
works but you want to parallelize it are
you sure it still works we'll just check
it using you know compare them
side-by-side and see if you still get
the same answer and this is really
common when you're trying to get rid of
a legacy system and with a replacement
system and you basically use the legacy
system as an Oracle for the replacement
system and you keep comparing the
outputs and if the outputs are always
the same then you have a good confidence
that your replacement system is actually
working the same way right so let me
talk about model-based testing all these
all these things have been property
based testing but sometimes any progress
testing we're dealing with pure
functions with you know they're very
deterministic they're very explicit in
terms you have this input you always get
this output so in the real world
sometimes you have things that aren't
that deterministic like a database
anything to do with it you know the real
world is sometimes more complicated and
so that we can use something called
model-based testing which is the test
Oracle approach for sort of real-world
things so let me show you how this works
let's say that you have a simple
database and you want to tests whether
it works a lot okay now a real database
is incredibly complex but we're going to
test our database with just four
operations
open the database connection close the
database connection increment a field in
a record and decrement a field in the
record and we're gonna have two
different clients because we want to
testaments currency and what we're going
to do is generate a random list of those
operations and so here we go fine a it's
just randomly says I pay you open and
then you increment and close and you
increment and you open and you close you
know and for client be open and then
decrement and open again and open again
and increment and so on so just a random
list of these four
equations now how do we actually use
this to check that our our database
actually works well what we do is we
take these operations and we run it on
the real system but at the same time we
take the same operations and we test it
on a very very simple model like an
in-memory accumulator in our case so
we're just adding and subtracting one in
the memory you know so for example in
our in our model we start off with zero
and then a increments it by one and then
be decremented by one now a tries to
increment it but a has closed their
database connections so nothing happens
and then you know so this is a our model
takes in the count whether the
connections open or closed
and then finally be tries to open it
tries to increment again and everything
works so if we do in our model after
running this we should expect that the
answer is 1 and if we went on a real
system we should also get the answer 1
and if we don't get the answer 1 then
our real-world database has at
concurrency bug in it so that's a quick
way of testing real-world systems and
there's a great example from John Hughes
who was one of the traitors of quick
check they had an airline library and
they there was this really painful bug
and they spent months trying to find out
what the buggy's and John Hughes
basically were tests to see if they
could reproduce it and he did reproduce
it and the steps were super bizarre to
reproduce you had to open and then
closed and then open a file and then
they had to three different operations
running in parallel to cause the problem
I'll actually show you this is actually
a slide from his presentation you open a
file close a file open a file in the
three different clients one client does
a lookup another client doesn't insert
and the third client also doesn't insert
at the
time and if this happens the database
file gets corrupted okay now what's
interesting is we have these bizarre
steps no human would ever think of
writing a test for this very very
bizarre you know why would you open and
close and reopen straightaway you know
so this was the the test case that the
quick check will found this issue pretty
fast and the shrinker is really
important part of this because you could
prolly find a test case where you do 20
different things in random order that's
not very helpful to understanding what
the problem is by using a shrinker you
can actually find the minimum test case
so in this case if you did two different
operations in parallel to clients that
wouldn't reproduce it you had to have
three different people doing these
things at the same time and that would
be the minimal thing that would have
fail so there's great John Hughes talked
about this from NGC Oslo to 2013 there's
the link if you want it by the way I
will put these slides on slack so you
can look at these slides later right so
let's just to finish up let's look at
the difference between example based
testing and probably based testing again
in probably based tests they're much
more general we're testing hundreds of
random inputs right which means that one
test one property based test can
actually have placed many example based
tests also they can reveal Ovilus
educators like when you're doing rant
when you're doing your example test you
tend not to think about strings with
non-printable characters you tend not to
think about massively negative numbers
or massively positive numbers and stuff
you know these things should be thought
about and nulls and so on probably based
testing they don't care they can just
randomly generate the stuff and they're
not human you know and the more of a
kind of deeper thought here is that
understanding requirements is tricky and
property taste tests force you to think
which is obviously a bad thing but if
you do want to think property based
tests will definitely make you think
about what
important when you're testing now
example based tests are still helpful
it's not it's not either/or it's and so
example based tests are great because
they are very easy to understand they're
less abstract they're very explicit sand
you know two plus two equals four is a
very nice little test to show me what
addition does in a very simple way so
it's a great way is in terms of
documentation if you really want to have
a thorough thorough testing they're not
so good for that but they're they both
have their place it's not either
you have to this one all the other one
you can use both example based tests and
probably based tests so to sum up be
lazy don't like tests generate them and
use property based tests thinking to
gain deeper insight into the
requirements so there's a bunch of
resources out there on the internet if
you search for property based testing
and your language you will find almost
certainly find something all the
functional languages have them a Python
has a really excellent one and I don't
know about PHP and so on but I'm sure
there is one a lot of a lot of the posts
you'll see on the Internet are kind of
theoretical but just like my one with
very simple examples but there are some
good real-world examples out there all
the John Hughes talks are great that's
the link to that one again he's got a
couple on property based testing there's
a really nice series of blog posts
[Music]
probably based testing in a screencast
editor like this is a real-world thing
with video how would you test that your
video editor is working pretty you're
watching it and there's an e-book there
as well too and also worth checking out
is metamorphic testing bye hello Wayne
and metamorphic testing is related to
property based testing in the sense that
you change things you don't know what
the right answer is
but again two different routes should
give you the same answer and the example
there is let's say you're doing image
recognition you're trying to do facial
recognition in an image well you don't
really know where the face is but if you
if you rotate the the source image the
facial recognition part should also be
rotated and if you make the input image
back and whites that shouldn't change
you know that should give you the same
location for the face and if you you
know change the colors on the input that
shouldn't change the output and so and
so you can actually do a lot of testing
to check the algorithms of correct even
without knowing what the right answer is
it's really knowing that two different
paths give to the same give you the same
answer
just like that before so that's worth
reading so thank you very much that's
the end of the talk if you want to have
any I'll be on slack off of this talk to
answer any questions I'll also post
these links on slack so it's easier to
read I have the slides and the video
will be up at my website F sharp on a
profit slash PBT I think I'm not sure if
we can do QA at this time I think well
I'm not sure and you hear me Martin